Today, I'm talking with Dr.
Rahul Basole, Associate Professor in
the School of Interactive Computing here
at Georgia Tech and a colleague of mine.
He and I actually worked together on the
research we're going to be describing.
Rahul, you're also the Director
of the Tennenbaum Institute
here at Georgia Tech.
Can you tell us about that?
>> Sure, the Tennenbaum Institute is a
multidisciplinary research institute at
Georgia Tech that draws on all
colleges here at the university.
And we're fundamentally interested in
how large, complex enterprises change
and we use a systems engineering
approach to study that.
>> And we were really brought
together when you decided to
use that approach to model the Center
for Health Discovery and Well Being,
a joint Emory/Georgia Tech project,
that helps people who have
risks of developing chronic
disease later in life.
Change their lifestyles and behavior
in order to litigate those risks.
We actually developed a business
strategy using this model and
we fit the needs of
all the stakeholders.
Doing this required modeling
all these interests.
Can you describe how that was done?
>> Certainly.
So this particular model
involved a four level approach.
Which consists of people, processes,
organizations and the ecosystem.
And there are interactions that occur
within and across these levels.
Each of these levels really
represents a stakeholder as well.
So at the people level,
we would look at providers and patients.
At the process level,
we would look at how these healthcare
processes are actually delivered,
which are often delivered by one or
more organizations to
third level in the model.
And ultimately,
they are ecosystemic forces that
impact all of these different levels.
>> Now the students are familiar with
the various approaches to modeling and
simulation.
So can you tell us which
approach was used at each level?
>> Definitely.
So, we did use
a multi-simulation paradigm
to approach this
particularly enterprise.
So at the people level, we used
an agent based modeling approach.
Processes tend to be model as
discreet event simulation.
But we also found that later on,
that agent based simulation was
actually quite appropriate.
The other two layers were done both with
systems dynamics, but all is age and
base modeling approaches.
>> So a mixture of different approaches?
>> Absolutely.
>> In one model?
>> That's correct.
>> So I know, because I was involved,
how difficult and
time consuming it was to get
the process layer defined.
Have you found that to be the case
in other healthcare projects and
what do you think is different about
healthcare that makes its processes so
different, so difficult to pin down?
>> Sure.
It's quite remarkable how
complex healthcare is.
So we found that process
modeling in itself in health
care is quite challenging,
as compared to other domains,
where it's actually very well defined.
Manufacturing is probably
the best example, where
you have well defined processes, and you
know how wages flow through the system.
In health care, you have enormous amount
of stakeholders have come together,
you have teams and collaborations, you
have patients moving through the system,
and all of that is sort of distributed
both geographically and also temporally,
and that makes process modeling
quite challenging with health care.
>> Collecting the discreet data
about events is also a challenge.
As opposed to manufacturing.
Can you talk about that a minute?
>> Certainly.
So I think that with an increasing
amount of digital data now in
healthcare as well,
it's still quite challenging to really
clearly lay out how processes happen.
So we can leverage lots of
different data sources with that.
Administrative data, clinical data,
but even that, can be very noisy,
can be very messy.
Sometimes there's missing data as well.
And then actually identifying sequences
of events in health care data
is actually very, very difficult.
>> So, we're now exploring a more
automated approach to that
called process mining.
Can you explain how that works?
>> Sure.
Process mining really has its roots
in the European academic disciplines.
What they have done is they have
used data mining approaches and
visualization to infer
processes from digital data.
And it involves lots of
sophisticated analytical tools.
And the idea is that,
can we use digital data to sequence
together how events map out?
>> So we've done some
preliminary work on that,
in the treatment of pediatric
asthma in the emergency department.
Can you tell us how that worked out?
>> Sure.
So we used digital data for
roughly 6,000 pediatric asthma patients,
and the idea was to obviously
identify variations in care by patient
strata, but also by providers and
the idea was to identify variations
in cost, quality and outcomes.
We have developed a tool, a visual
analytic tool, that could actually map
different processes and allows you
to filter by different criteria,
across patient strata, providers,
patient demographic data.
And this visual analytic tool can
be used by clinicians to explore
how processes are delivered, where there
might be actual differences in care,
and potentially, how to improve them.
>> So I'm sure the students at this
point, near the end of the course,
can appreciate just how challenging what
Rahul just described is to do in
practice, given all of the problems
we've discussed throughout the course
in terms of the interoperability of
the systems from which the data
needs to be collected.
The differences in the way
the data's represented,
the data quality as we
mentioned a few minutes ago.
A really exciting area and
you should stay tuned,
see what we end up doing in a few years.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.